When I was a kid, I wanted to be a spy.
The midnight phone calls.
The cool gadgets.
The secret missions.
But I grew up.
I changed.
And I’m living out those dreams on a slightly
different path.
Now, I’m a full-time digital storyteller, which means
late nights wrapping up projects, an expensive
video camera, and some non-disclosure agreements.
And I got here by setting small goals that
were clear, doable, and ambitious.
I know things can seem a bit overwhelming
when you’re out of school, there are no
more grades, and all of a sudden people are
talking about five-year plans when it feels
like you don’t know what’s happening in
five weeks.
But we’ve got you.
So today, your mission -- should you choose
to accept it -- is to learn how to set achievable
goals.
I’m Evelyn from the Internets.
And this is Crash Course Business: Soft Skills.
[Intro Music Plays]
Let’s face it, we all have dreams.
And we all want to achieve them, no matter
if they’re big like, “I want to write
an Oscar-winning screenplay” or small, like,
“I just want to finish this script, right now."
Looking toward the future is scary and muddled.
Every little decision you make seems like
it’s really high stakes.
At some point, your hopes and fears and insecurities
might get all mixed together as your brain
starts to panic, and all of a sudden you’re
having a quarter-life crisis in your 20s.
Like, “Am I actually achieving anything
in my life?”
I know I’ve been there.
But you can limit this anxiety by setting
some SMART goals that break down your big
plans into manageable steps.
And I don’t mean “smart” like responsible,
although it never hurts to budget your travel
expenses or think about building a 401k.
Your parents would be proud.
SMART is another one of those business-y acronyms.
It stands for Specific, Measurable, Ambitious,
Realistic, and Timely.
So first of all, your SMART goal should be
specific, clear, and easy to understand.
“Do your best” may be a great mantra or
motivational poster, but it’s too vague
to be a helpful goal.
Breaking down a big goal into smaller, specific
action steps will let you see results, which
will lower that “am I actually getting anywhere?”
anxiety.
Second, you can’t see results without
knowing what they look like, which is why
SMART goals should also be measurable.
If you’re not measuring anything, how are
you going to look back at everything you’ve
accomplished?
So make sure each step comes with numbers
to help you see clear benchmarks.
For example, instead of “stop the bad guy
and save the world,” try “complete 3 missions
from M this month.”
Now, you might be tempted to set relatively
easy small goals, so you can check them off
and fill that craving we all have for instant
gratification.
But you should also be ambitious with your
SMART goal.
You’ll work harder and your results will
last longer if you’re challenged.
Like, you probably didn’t pay attention
in classes where you were bored.
Then, you want to strike a balance between
challenging and realistic SMART goals.
Unless you’re Tom Cruise, mission impossible
really needs to be mission challenging-yet-probable.
Goals that are too ambitious can be frustrating,
rather than motivating.
You might be making gradual progress.
But if you don’t hit that super-far-out
target, you might have a nagging feeling that
you’re a failure… and that can really
weigh you down.
It’s kind of like being upset that you didn’t
lock up the bad guy forever, and losing
sight of the fact that you still thwarted
his evil plan.
If you want to push a little bit farther,
you can set a stretch goal.
But make sure there’s a minimum where you’re
still happy.
It’s like Kickstarter for your brain!
Like, if you’ve spiffed up your secret underground
base, your stretch goal may be to build yourself
another jetpack!
And finally, make sure your SMART goals are
always timely.
Because without a timeline, you might keep
pushing your goal off to… someday.
And when you get busy, someday never seems
to come.
If your big goals are complex, like “run
your own spy agency by age 25,” you may
need 3 to 4 subgoals with smaller timelines,
like, “stop Shego 4 times this year” or
“partner with Wade to create a new gadget
this month.”
And remember when we talked about under promising
and over delivering?
We all generally have a hard time understanding
how long things are going to take.
So set a few incremental deadlines, so you
won’t be up doing an entire project the
night before.
But find a balance.
Tight deadlines can be motivating but also
really stressful.
If you’ve got 24 hours to stop a supervillain,
you’ll work fast, but your blood pressure
may be through the roof.
Now, if you’re trying to process all these
tips and still aren’t entirely sure what
you’re aiming for in the first place, make
your SMART goal a learning goal.
Learning goals, like setting up an informational
interview per week, help you figure out what
you need to do and what goals you should set
as benchmarks along that path.
But even if you put a lot of work into crafting
some awesome, motivating SMART goals, life
can just… happen.
Things change.
Your priorities might shift as you learn more
about yourself, or you could have to deal
with an unexpected setback like an injury
or layoff, which can send anyone reeling.
So if you feel you need to adjust your timeline
or abandon a goal, it’s not necessarily
a failure, even though it might feel like
one.
It’s gonna be okay.
There’s only so much time in a day, and
goal quality matters more than goal quantity.
So you’ve got to think about what’s most
important to you.
If you’re trying to save the world and also
study for that math test, you may need to
put a 4.0 GPA on the backburner.
But there’s a difference between adjusting
priorities and giving up with a “what the
heck!” just because something got hard.
Balancing ambitious and realistic goals can
be tough, so be flexible with yourself.
If you’re trying to save money, maybe say,
“I’m going to cook for myself this whole
month… except for brunch on Sundays with
my girls.”
[Evelyn can also swap this & the next line
out for a personal example]
And if think you might struggle, set yourself
a fail-safe.
It’s like a gentle consequence that pressures
you to stay on track.
Like if you go out more than once, you have
to buy everyone’s mimosas.
Goals and their fail-safes are powerful because
a lot of times, they’re about personal growth
-- the stuff that intrinsically motivates
you.
But other times goals have extrinsic rewards,
like money or fame or power.
There’s nothing wrong with doing a job for
the cash -- private investigators can still
bring in bad guys.
But sometimes, extrinsic motivators can make
people want to game the system.
Not necessarily because they’re bad people
doing bad things, but because the incentive
structure is wrong.
To see what I mean, let’s go to the Thought
Bubble.
Let’s imagine you run a scrappy auto shop
in the heart of Gotham.
With all those robberies and high-speed chases,
your work was steady... before a questionably
dressed vigilante cleaned up the streets.
Now, things are in a bit of a lull.
So you set a goal for your auto mechanics
to bring in $150 dollars per hour.
Your intent was good.
But when you show up to work the next day,
there’s a really upset customer who thinks
his Batmobile has spent too much time in the
shop.
It turns out that this high pressure goal
led your mechanics to overcharge and do unnecessary
work to raise their hourly sales.
You hoped that your sales targets would increase
their work quantity without affecting the
quality.
Instead, you rewarded them for increasing
billable hours by keeping cars in the shop
for too long… which is unethical.
Essentially, in the words of business professors,
you “rewarded for A while hoping for B”
To avoid falling into that trap, make sure
your goal actually encourages the behaviors
you want.
Think about the worst behavior you could accidentally
encourage and take precautions.
To deter mechanics from doing unnecessary
work, you could create a ‘why so serious
sales initiative’ and put customer satisfaction
survey links at the bottom of every receipt.
Or you could set a flat price for each kind
of repair and monitor how long cars are in
your shop with a detailed record system.
And everyone likes appreciation, so giving
them /specific/ positive feedback for meeting
goals in good ways can help keep your shop
under control.
Thanks, Thought Bubble!
SMART goals aren’t just for solo missions.
If you’re a team of unstoppable super spies,
goals get everyone on the same page.
But setting personal, individual project goals
for other people could lead to a mission breakdown.
People have different priorities.
Your demolitions expert probably cares about
different things than your data guy.
And no one likes directives from an out-of-touch
bureaucrat.
Or you may underestimate what your teammates
are capable of and set a goal that’s not
ambitious enough.
After all, many people put more pressure on
themselves than anyone else does.
Or you could target the wrong incentives,
and a pay bonus for the most missions completed
in a month could lead to team competition
instead of cooperation.
So, bringing everyone together to agree on
one overarching team goal and set some individual
goals will be motivating!
And it’ll keep people from working against
each other [like Mr. and Mrs. Smith.]
Even if your goals line up, no team is perfect.
But clear communication, progress reports,
and feedback will help your mission run smoothly.
And after all this goal talk, if you still
don’t exactly feel like you know what
you’re doing or know how to reach your dreams…
welcome to adulthood.
[Kidding.
Sort of.]
I’ve said it before and I’ll say it again.
No one knows everything.
No one is perfect.
And everyone’s gotta start somewhere.
So, if you or your team miss it by that much,
it’s okay.
The best thing to do is to learn from your
mistakes.
And keep moving forward to go after those
goals!
So if you remember nothing else from today:
Reduce goal anxiety by setting a SMART goal
that’s both ambitious and realistic.
Prioritize your goals.
As long as you’re not just giving up, having
to table a goal isn’t a failure.
It’s being smart about your time.
Avoid mission breakdown.
Work with your team to set group goals that
consider everyone’s priorities.
Set the right metrics.
Make sure your goal doesn’t incentivize
the wrong behavior and reward for A while
hoping for B.
Next time, we’ll be talking about how to
get better at time management.
Because we can all improve.
I know you’ve said “ehhh, just one more
episode” at least once in your life.
Crash Course Business is sponsored by Google and it’s made with the help of all
these nice people and Thought Cafe is our
amazing animation team.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like Healthcare Triage, where host
Dr. Aaron Carroll explains healthcare policy,
medical research, and answers a lot of other
questions you may have about medicine, health,
and healthcare.
Also, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.